la question c'est comment récupérer le
pouvoir sur ces technocrates qui décide
de tout qui nous prive de notre
autonomie qui nous prive de toute
décision il faut qu'on arrête de dire
qu'on est en démocratie c'est un
mensonge
et c'est un mensonge qui est très long à
déconstruire
moi j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à lire
des textes pour essayer de comprendre le
néolibéralisme etc
et je refuse que des journalistes disent
qu'on est en démocratie aujourd'hui
c'est pas vrai il faut arrêter de dire
ça c'est une république élective
c'est une aristocratie et des qui fait
une oligarchie n'est pas une démocratie
depuis que je suis né j'ai eu aucune
prise sur le monde dans lequel je vis et
dans lequel je fait naître mes enfants
donc il faut commencer à nommer des
choses et arrêter de confier aux
personnes qui nous ont construit ce
monde qui est désastreux qui était
complètement inhumain et qui est en
train de devenir de plus en plus
inhumain
il ya de moins en moins d'endroits
devant on est en plein d'idées à
l'extinction de masse et toutes ces
questions là c'est la même chose en fait
que le confinement c'est à dire qu'en
texte qu'on reprend le pouvoir et
comment
[Musique]